i
[Música]
hola amigas y amigos
me siento complacido de estar en esta
serie de charlas de tx y hoy quiero
hacerles una exposición de una
problemática que está afectando
gravemente a la humanidad que es la
escasez de agua potable
o no al principios de este milenio
declaro en su objetivo 7 garantizar la
sostenibilidad del medio ambiente y en
una de sus estrategias de ese objetivo
expresó muy claramente reducir a un 50
por ciento para año 2015
el porcentaje de personas que no tienen
acceso al agua potable de inmediato la
organización mundial de la salud
informó que 2.2 por ciento 2.2 millones
de personas
fallecen o se enferman gravemente por
ingerir aguas contaminadas estoy
hablando de principios del milenio hace
19 años
esto es para reflexionar
a preguntarse encontrar soluciones ver
todos los motivos la curiosidad de la
vida en todos sus aspectos es el secreto
de las personas creativas de las
personas que investigan porque hay que
preguntar para crecer en conocimientos y
en experiencias
hay que preguntar para saber por qué tal
problema
cuando somos niños
preguntamos todos estamos explorando el
mundo
explorando muchas cosas que estamos
encontrando no tenemos pena en preguntar
y cuando crecíamos no se así por vanidad
orgullo o 212
ya no preguntamos tanto y la manera más
rápida de información es preguntar a los
que saben
los libros te dicen mucho no todo el
internet te dice mucho no todo y a veces
esta basura
pero preguntar a el experto tienes un 95
por ciento de probabilidad de tener una
respuesta correcta a lo que estás
preguntando
y yo que me pregunte
si el 75% del planeta tierra está
formado de agua porque escasea
comencé a preguntar antes que nada a los
expertos les investigue y encuentre
cuatro causas
1 el crecimiento poblacional
que demanda mayor consumo de agua 2
el crecimiento de actividades agrícolas
3 el crecimiento de la industria y
cuarto la contaminación
entonces había muchos retos que vencer
al entender lo que estaba pasando
de inmediato yo siempre quise hacer un
doctorado
por razones de trabajo familiares
no se pudo en un momento dado cuando
termine mi gestión de director en la
facultad ingeniería química en el 2004
fui becado y fui aceptado en la
universidad politécnica de cataluña de
barcelona para hacer mi doctorado
estaba yo maquillan ustedes
contento motivado tenía 58 años
y ahí empieza cómo se llama el tema de
trx me reinicio me reinicio académico
pero no como profesor lo hacía un
momento angular como alumno como alumno
del doctorado
tener las ganas la motivación de hacerlo
y me fui a barcelona de inmediato me
recibió el director del programa y me
dijo jorge eres ingeniero químico
tenemos aquí un tema muy importante que
puedes
y ayudar a muchos el agua
procesos que no contaminen procesos de
bajos costos procesos que no consuman
mucha energía
déjeme estudiarlo bien porque necesito
conocer todos los procesos para que yo
pueda presentar un trabajo con
innovación es un trabajo original me
dijo adelante inmediato le conecta
internet encontré una empresa en islas
canarias y me fui
me recibieron
me dieron muchísima información y la
misma los mismos directivos ya sea
empresa
me llevaron a todas las siete islas a
conocer todos los procesos y algunas
otras que hay en españa también este las
conocí y yo con mi matriz foda y la metí
la fuerza todos la conocen la meta se
usa mucho en europa que es materiales
energía y toxicidad así que tengo 4 y 37
variables importantes para analizar los
cuatro los procesos y de ahí decir cuál
es el estado de la técnica cuál es el
estado del arte cuál es el mejor proceso
para que yo pueda partir del
innovaciones de ese proceso que es el
mejor
y empecé a investigar empecé a notar
empecé a avanzar el primer doctorado
había conferencias y asistí a una que no
se me olvida del doctor pedro arrojo
experto en aguas
que me quedó grabado sus conclusiones
cuando hablo de sus tres conceptos del
agua agua vida agua social y agua disney
agua vida se entiende no hay vida sin
agua agua social un derecho para todos y
agua business agua como negocio
estaba yo ya muy motivado en esta etapa
debido auto grado muy conectado veríamos
seguir investigando y ya una vez de
analizar los cuatro procesos que
encontré eso sí es inversa convencional
evaporación destilación y compresión de
vapor
viendo todas sus variables sus
comportamientos de los procesos porque
los vi funcionar
y vi que el mejor era o ciencia inversa
convencional es el estado de la técnica
ese es el estado del arte y de ahí tiene
que a partir y comencé a hacer mis
investigaciones el componente principal
para la dos veces inversa es la membrana
es el medio filtrante el agua de mar
contiene 35 mil partes por millón de
sólidos es un montón
entonces las membranas es el equipo
principal y como cuando fui director
hice un convenio con el politécnico en
la ciudad de toulouse en francia que son
expertos en membranas me aceptaron hacer
una estancia de ocho meses y vivían
toulouse aprender todos los deben brand
as y como siempre preguntar a los
expertos preguntar para crecer preguntar
para avanzar y ahí estuve investigando
haciendo innovaciones y entonces empecé
en contar las primeras innovaciones y
como decía steve jobs
la innovación distingue al líder del
seguidor
yo continué con mis innovaciones
fui a presentar ponencias a varios
lugares del mundo fui a publique
artículos científicos en revistas
arbitradas
y regresé a barcelona ya tenía yo un
proyecto establecido o un pre proyecto
le dije señores a los del comité de
tutorial ya tengo el proyecto que voy a
presentar que voy a hacer ya tiene
nombre y apellido
se llama proceso de desalinización de
agua de mar por razones inversa de tipo
centrífuga
con generación de vórtices de dyn
quizás aquí lo que haga un poco le decir
ortiz este link
hago una analogía
ahora en cuenta nos sentábamos en una
taza de café la griego endulcorante o
azúcar y la huevo que podemos remolino
no ese remolino es un vórtice para que
el azúcar se distribuya lo dejó de mover
se vuelve a sentar vuelva a mover ya
termina el café y quedó un pequeño
crecido en el fondo lo mismo es el
vórtice que yo utilicé las membranas son
como popotes caña que llaman en españa
popote
de un milímetro de diámetro y tienen
unos microporos a los lados de la pared
del popote entonces allá entra el agua a
presión y además centrifugación
hay que tener mucho cuidado con la
velocidad de entrada con la velocidad de
revoluciones de la centrifugación y
también con la geometría de las
membranas cuál es el material que debe
utilizar y qué geometría tienen y con
eso formó la participa
qué es la obesidad consciente a los
sólidos evita que se peguen a las
paredes y los microporos deja en
libertad a que el agua se empieza a
permear el auto es convencional se
lograban 40 por ciento de premiado luz
60 de rechazo con mi propuesta un 50 por
ciento de premiado y un 50 de rechazo
hubo un incremento de productividad el
ahorro y si es convencional hay que
pagar en un turno de 24 horas siete
veces para limpiar membranas porque se
incrustan los los sólidos en mi caso y
hay que parar la autolimpieza la hacen
los vórtices y en vez de que dura un año
la membrana de la ayuda de tres años
y tengo mayor preñado menos consumo de
energía menores costos de producción y
no contaminación
un proceso sustentable ya teniendo todo
en orden este reinicio tiene su
culminación
una sublimación
el día en examen de grado
que me acompañó a mi familia cómo está
hoy
me dieron fortaleza fue motivo para mí
muy emotivo que estén ahí hay los
exámenes son públicos abiertos los
sinodales más la gente que invitan en
barcelona está
la empresa akbar aguas de barcelona
donde hay mucha gente experta y estaban
en examen
entonces al final ellos sin duda les me
preguntaron
servir al presidente señores invitados
alguien tiene alguna pregunta para jorge
adelante y 3 me preguntaron yo contesté
porque estaba seguro de lo que estaba
presentando conteste terminó mi examen
obtuve el grado de doctor
todo para mí fue una culminación con
éxito estaba yo muy motivado y muy
emocionado
pero gracias a dios esa gran oportunidad
que me dio
regrese
a méxico me incorporé a la facultad de
ingeniería química la universidad
de inmediato patentó el proceso
en eeuu y en méxico los pacientes ya se
otorgaron el 2016 y el 2017 que es una
protección que le dan a un proceso oa un
producto en este caso un proceso
actualmente estoy trabajando en la
facultad la construcción de un equipo
piloto para hacer pruebas ya tengo un 90
por ciento de avance de lo que es el
equipo vamos es decir de prueba para
empezar a hacer comprobaciones si
realmente hay esa tasa de conversión si
realmente hay autolimpieza y esto hasta
que sea tangible totalmente yo puedo
probar y decir si esto se cumple y
estamos en 90 por ciento
en
le quiero dar también
un reconocimiento a todos los profesores
que me apoyaron
una frase de ever harrison
qué dice un profesor es como una brújula
que orienta sus imanes hacia el
conocimiento hacia la curiosidad y hacia
la sabiduría en sus alumnos
ahora que nos queda que nos resta
contribuir
con lo que uno sabe por lo que ya hemos
escuchado anteriormente las
problemáticas que hay del medio ambiente
y la falta de agua
si todos nos juntamos nos unimos
cada quien en su especialidad podemos
contribuir para hacer un mejor planeta
sobre todo para las nuevas generaciones
dejar es un planeta mejor pero nosotros
recibimos
yo me comprometo en la parte que me
corresponde lo que es el agua trabajar
mucho apoyar mucho con el agua
patrimonio de la vida muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]